hey how's it going bros my name is Peter
ba just wanted to make a quick video to
say thanks I know it's a bit redundant
okay but I realized that I never really
got a chance to fully express my
gratitude for all the support that I've
gotten throughout these past couple days
I don't think I've gotten this much
support ever of me making videos these
past six years on YouTube and it really
turned this shitty situation completely
around and all the support that I've
been getting from you guys has just been
incredible
it seemed that people that doesn't even
necessarily consume my content came to
support me throughout this whole thing
with the media because they thought the
whole situation was unjustified there's
any newcomers domo arigato thank you
very much
why why am i awkward in I also didn't
realize how much it would mean to me the
fact that so many people supported me
because I didn't think I need it but
when it seems like the whole world is
kind of turned against you and is after
blood to have people defending you even
when you haven't gotten the chance to
defend yourself it really means a lot
it's something that I know I will never
forget it was it was almost like the
internet had my back throughout this
whole situation and that has just been
so incredibly cool cuz that's really all
I care about and I didn't make my way to
where I am thanks to the media I didn't
get where I am through them I I made my
way through the internet and and through
you guys and thanks to you guys watching
me and if you guys are still supporting
me that means everything to me like I
couldn't care less what the media thinks
about me and what they say about me and
it clearly all bridges are seem almost
burnt at this point but the fact that
you guys had my back it means everything
it's weird because I I saw this coming I
said it in a video earlier this year I
think what I said was something like
2017 it's the year it's gonna go bad for
me alright I'm just calling it out right
right now you want you get out before
you can't because put it pious he's a
bad boy
ain't you i entice cymatic what other
labels can we put him hit letter loving
the media wants to paint me as some sort
of villain so it went a lot faster and a
lot harder than I thought but I knew it
was gonna happen because I I let all
guards down like I've been so tired of
everything that I say being taken out of
context like even before and I it's
almost like I have to think what I say
now in every single video because
someone else might watch it that isn't
necessarily my audience and they might
take that one part out of it and put it
on a headline and it's just so stupid
but I realized I'm not gonna censor
myself for that I I should care about
the ones that actually watch my content
and what they think about it and and I
think if anything that's been more clear
and obvious to me than ever
obviously I'm not gonna see this as some
way to kind of provoke or start drama I
have really really no intentions I'm
doing that there's been so much with the
drama with the media these past couple
months but it's really not some it's not
something I thrive on it's not something
that I feel like what can I do next if
anything what I realized throughout this
whole thing is that I really really
really just care about entertaining my
audience a lot of people have been
saying oh well he lost so much he lost
his show and all these things but all
these things are possible and if
anything now I'm independent for the
first time in four years or five years
and I feel great I feel really really
excited about what opportunities that's
gonna bring in and if I didn't know
better I would say thank you to the Wall
Street Journal actually thank you Wall
Street Journal there's been a very busy
couple of days for me and I'm sorry if
the continent hasn't really been up to
standard but I feel more committed and
more passionate than I want to do
something bigger about this whole thing
but I I can't say what it is but that's
for the future but anyway what I want to
say is you guys [ __ ] Rock you you you
you're [ __ ] awesome I feel like I
don't deserve it but
thank you thank you very much I'm ready
to keep making videos and love you also
by the way JK Rowling is still a